[Music]
all right we are live um I think you
know my name I think you know what show
you're watching um this is an
extremely uh well it's an upsetting day
and an upsetting time and I honestly I'm
just going to be very upfront with you
at the beginning here I have no idea uh
what kind of show we're about to do or
if we're going to even do a full show or
anything else I have a show planned we
have plenty of paper and clips and a
whole bunch of stuff and we just got rid
of probably 10 pages of other stuff and
all of that um but I don't know what the
best way to do this is um there are a
million shows on every side of the
political and ideological and I suppose
religious and philosophical spectrum
that everyone can be watching right now
to have all of their uh preconceived
notions reinforced and go into their
ideological bubble and all of those
things and I suppose I'm one of those
people and I think over the last couple
years um or since I've been doing this
show I've tried really really hard to uh
talk about things as honestly as
possible I I mean how often on the show
do I play clips of Jordan Peterson to
talk talking about truth and why it's
important when I started doing this show
in the first
place um I I was trying to do it to
bring on people from every side of the
aisle to talk about all the these things
because in any kind of civilized society
in any kind of nation that any of us
could be blessed to live in uh if you
don't talk about the things honestly if
you don't know what's true and not true
if you don't um if you can't sit across
from somebody who think something
differently than you then you will end
up killing each other and there's an
awful lot of death and destruction
happening right now and it's not by
accident it's actually quite by Design
and I I guess I have to do a show now
where I explain a little bit of it to
you and show you some things um I have
no doubt that you have seen some of the
things that I have seen uh over the
weekend I I've seen some of the most
vile
disgusting uh things imaginable um and
some of the things that you're probably
seeing on Twitter I've seen worse things
that were sent to me uh from people on
the ground in Israel um that are like
they're
literally there are not words to
describe them right right
like like you can describe them like
like women being
raped uh with their dead husband laying
next to them and and children being
snatched from their mothers and all of
these things um and we're going to we're
going to play one compilation of just
some of the horror because I do think
that it's important to see some of the
horror I suppose um I I should note that
in about 15 minutes or so I don't know
how long we'll do this portion of the
show uh I have Gotti tab is an Israeli
journalist and historian he's he's a
great guy uh he's in Israel right now in
Tel Aviv uh we have him on on Skype at
the moment so we'll get to him in about
15 minutes and he can explain he's a
really really clear thinker uh I
consider him a good friend I did a
couple events with him when I was in
Israel um I should just note that you
know we were in Israel in
May and my my main takeaway from being
in Israel was um was how peaceful it was
actually actually that was the thing if
you watched our videos you know my
little handheld videos where we were
walking through the city of Jerusalem
and you see you know Muslim women in
full garb walking next to um Ultra
Orthodox Israeli men and it's and it's
peaceful and there is coexistence and um
maybe that'll be completely Fray now and
then the funny thing is that peace and
coexistence is not the default position
of it's actually not the default
position of humanity right and it's not
the default position of what happens
usually in the history of the holiest
city on the face of the Earth it is a
place that has been conquered and
reconquered and conquered again and
reconquered again over time and in the
75 years of Israel's of the modern state
of Israel's existence because the state
of Israel has always existed and the
Jewish people have always been in the
land of Israel um since Israel took over
Jerusalem specifically after the 1967
war where before that it was controlled
by Jordan there never was anything known
as a Palestinian State I can explain
some of that to you too because people
are very confused about things Jews were
not even allowed to pray at the Western
Wall they weren't allowed to go there
the Hol site it was basically a toilet
for the jordanians um Israel reunified
the city and they brought peace together
where Arabs and Jews and Muslims and
Christians and these people coexist and
they pray and they pray and they live
and they are involved in Commerce and
everything else and my takeaway after it
was particularly the 5 days in Jerusalem
which actually just before we started
the show the last tweet that I saw is
now that Rockets are landing on
Jerusalem so these people who you know
purport to be doing this for religious
reasons they also have no problem
shooting rockets at Jerusalem right I
mean and these Rockets are completely
indiscriminate so they could just as
easily blow up a a mosque which there
are plenty of mosques in Jerusalem or or
hit a Muslim family or or anything
else um but peace is not the default
position of humans and no matter how
hard you try to achieve peace um there
are going to be people that are going to
try to take that peace away um and that
has been the story of 75 years I suppose
of Israel the modern state of Israel's
existence just quickly I I really I
apologize if this is somewhat rambling
or something but just quickly for all of
the people and many of them are on MSNBC
these trash hacks who are
corporate hacks who are paid to lie and
then and then the buffoons who spread
their message and I also have a certain
amount of for young people who are
completely confused about this because
the left and all of the inst all the
stuff that we talk about they have
confused a generation of young kids up
down left right boys or girls all the
stuff this is all connected it's all
connected because if you don't know what
is true you will literally be cheering
on as women are raped and children are
killed and stripped away from their
parents um you will be cheering on the
bad guys now I'm happy to see that
actually most of the Civilized world
seems to be on the right side of this
thing but obviously there's going to be
a certain set of people at the New York
Times and and just sort of the
brainwashed dullards who will not uh but
I I would quickly just try to um dispel
one sort of R it's not even a rumor one
complete fallacy about the land of
Israel 75 years the modern state of
Israel has existed before that the state
of Palestine was not a Palestinian state
for Palestinian Arabs there were Arabs
that lived there there were Jews that
lived there there were Christians that
lived there it was part of something
called the British Empire which lasted
for a long time before that the British
Empire ended and then they said we we
have this partition plan Jews you can
take some of the land Arabs you can take
some land there weren't even people
called Palestinians at the time they
were known as Arabs okay with the
Palestine post which is now the
Jerusalem Post now was basically a
Jewish paper the Palestinian soccer team
was Jews when they talk about Palestine
they're talking about the place where
the Jews live the Arab armies used to
the Arab countries used to boycott
Palestine because that's where the Jews
live the story of Hanukkah have you ever
heard of this story when the Jews were
defending themselves from the Greeks are
in the hills of Judea Judea and Samaria
right a guy named Jesus Christ uh lived
in Bethlehem uh yeah in what they call
Palestine he was a Jew
okay anyway I could give you a history
lesson all day long but people are so
confused about so much of this and and
not and the only reason it's important
to know history is to dispel some of the
nonsense now but there was the British
Empire there was the Ottoman Empire
before that so all of these people and I
see this now from all of these whack job
lunatics and they're promoted on MSNBC
and the New York Times we should just
end the 75-year occupation well that's
rather interesting that a whole series
of people are calling for the British to
reoccupy the state of Palestine in any
event uh the modern state of Israel
which has become a light unto the
nations in that it is a western society
that has more there's only one place in
the Middle East that has coexistence
there's only one place in the the Middle
East where Jews and Christians and
Muslims share buses and go to
restaurants together and everything else
right there are no Jews in any of the
other countries to speak of there's like
there's literally I met one I was in
Egypt in 1997 there was one Jew that
they were really proud of there was one
Jew and he was scared trust me I met
this guy and I'm sure he's dead now um
so there are no Jews in any of these
countries there are no how's it going
for Christians in any Muslim country the
point is there is one place that is
anti-apartheid in all of the Middle East
there is one place that has any to do
with sharing any of our values and
because everything is so upside down all
of the other issues that I talk about on
this show and the lack of truth that we
have from our so-called leaders and
everything else that up is down and left
is right and bad guys are good guys and
everything else and everything else
Falls because of
that all right so let me try to do some
kind let me try to just get you kind of
caught up on some of this and um and we
shall go from there I suppose so uh I've
got some info from the daily wire just
on the on the state of kind of where
we're at at the moment uh Israel
declared war an allout state of War on
Saturday after Palestinian terrorists
repeatedly fired thousands of rockets
from inside Gaza and while dozens of
Highly armed terrorists infiltrated
parts of Israel opening fire on innocent
civilians the attacks were carried out
by Hamas an Islamic terrorist group that
is funded in part by Iran during the
holiday of simat Torah and on Shabbat
the Jewish day of rest that is observed
by many in Israel terrorist Muhammad
daif hamas's military Chief said that
his militants fired 5,000 Rockets into
Israel as part of operation Al oxis
storm he called for surrounding Islamic
Nations to join the palestin Palestinian
terrorists in their attacks on Israel
images and videos circulating on social
media that were reported on by various
newswires major newspapers and local
Publications showed horrifying scenes as
Rockets smashed into the side of
residential buildings cars and at least
one military tank were on fire numerous
bodies lay on the ground in pools of
blood the bodies of Israeli soldiers
were desecrated by Palestinians and
Islamic terrorists roam the streets
hunting for Israeli citizens there were
also reports that hostages may have been
taken Israeli soldiers and potentially
civilians and it appears that the
terrorists were able to steal
significant military hardware um just a
quick update on the death toll there are
over
1200 um dead Israelis at the moment uh
more than 2,500 are injured they don't
know how many people have been kidnapped
by Hamas uh we know that many of them
are Americans also it is a little
bizarre that the United president of the
United States or the man pretending to
be president of the United States hasn't
at the very least demanded that Hamas
give back the Americans but he has not
done that as of yet um and I think
that's deeply connected to having us we
gave Iran $6 billion dollar Donald Trump
Ronda santis almost everyone across the
board on the on the scary right right
the evil Nazis of the right right um
were saying that this was going to lead
to terrorism and and here we are um just
quickly let me just back up for a second
on something that I said a moment ago
related to the history so after the
founding of Israel in 1948 when the Jews
said yes we'll take some land and you
guys take some land the Palestinians the
Palestinians they were not known as
Palestinians the Arabs said no it was a
partition plan for the Jews and the
Arabs the Arabs said no all of the Arab
armies attacked Israel and Israel won in
in a basically a complete absolute
extraordinary God created miracle I
think that's the only way you can
describe it and then until 1967 Israel
remained the same size then the Arabs
attacked again and then Israel
reconquered the West Bank which again
that's Juda and Samaria where Jesus was
from which was part of Jordan so when
they tell you the occupation began in
1967 are you calling for the Jordanian
occupation of quote unquote Palestine
and Egypt had Gaza right Egypt shares a
border with Gaza until
1967 also in
2005 in 2005 the Israelis had about I
think 8,000 people living in Gaza they
took them all out they ripped them out
of their homes they left temples they
left green houses they said we just want
nothing to do with you people there
there are no Jews there are no Israelis
living in Gaza uh Gaza also shares a
border with Egypt Egypt completely
closed the Border everyone blames Israel
for that of course um but point is they
took everybody out they said we want
nothing to do with you in the hopes for
peace and of course you don't get peace
I don't think anyone would have thought
that it would have been this absolutely
psychotically horrific uh but you know I
mentioned uh a moment ago that they you
know they call all of the people on the
right right what have we been through
for the last couple years everyone who
doesn't bow to the woke left and all
these things and again these things are
connected everyone that doesn't bow to
these people what are we call what are
we called We're called Nazis right and
right now you have actual this is the
modern Nazi movement what happened to
the Jews of Europe before the state of
Israel before
1948 pgrs and people going house to
house Nazis killing people shooting them
doing horrible experiments on children
unimaginable things UNF
imaginable things okay I grew up with
Holocaust survivors on both side of my
family with people that had numbers on
their arms and my my
uh my uncle who married into my family
my Uncle Jerry uh his father was a
survivor of the Holocaust who lived with
a bullet in him for the rest of his life
uh because they was too close to his
heart that they couldn't remove it um
his daughter was kid like like that
is unimaginable and it's happening right
now and it has nothing to do with an
occupation or anything else it is an
absolute abject evil blood lust from
these people who don't want Jews to have
a sliver a SLI
on this Earth it is as simple as that it
is not more complex than that if you if
you are somehow in the moment
sympathetic to the Palestinian side
right now um you have to explain how
murdering and raping women and children
anything is a just way to accomplish
your objective do you think they're
going to get a state after this do you
think they're going to get anything
after this of course not do you think
Egypt's going to open up their border
Israel has to do what it has to do in
Gaza right now like there's just no
doubt about it you just don't lay over
and die right they didn't want this they
left they left 17 years ago it didn't
buy them an ounce of Grace from the rest
of the world or for anyone else Egypt
will not has bombed the out of that
border over the years and flooded
tunnels as gazin want to get over to
Egypt Sinai is basically empty Sinai is
basically an empty territory that's
probably 50 times the size of Israel
might be 100 times the size of Israel
check a map they don't want anyone
living there they could take all the
Palestinians tomorrow they don't want
them either notice that no Arab nation
is going to welcome their brothers right
now
right um can we get a map can you get a
map I'm going to can I text you a map
that we could just put up during the
show right now or we'll put it up in a
moment because people don't understand
the basic geography even of this
um Conor I'm texting it to
you I'm just we can put it up in a
moment Conor just I just texted it to
you um all right so while while we look
at that and again I I know I'm a little
over the place here um this is a
two-minute compilation video of some of
the abject just horrendous things and I
really don't know if I'm supposed to
show this to you but if we don't see
this we will not know what we are up
against and when I say we it's all of
Wester it's all of the Western World the
people that are chanting Pro Palestinian
uh slogans in Sydney Australia and in
Ontario Canada and in New York City
right now they would gladly do the same
things to us in America and in all of
the West do you not think that they
think America isn't on Stolen land do
you not think that they don't think that
uh Australia is on Stolen Land from the
Aborigines do you not think that they
think that Canada is on Stolen Land from
the indigenous people and all of the
things and and we all should have been
paying attention to this way more way
more do you have the map yet or we'll
throw to the video first yeah all right
we're going to throw to this video first
you've probably seen some of this and
believe me this is not the worst this is
not the worst but all
[Music]
right
foree out
[Music]
allahar
I believe me we could have shown you
worse that kid is now in Gaza what do he
looks like a four-year-old boy is now in
Gaza they took there was a video of a
woman who's a holocaust Survivor who's
probably 85 years old being abused by
these Savage medieval
um you don't negotiate with these
people you don't say oh we'll just give
you oh you did just rap my wife and kill
my family and we'll just give you a
little land now a little land now right
like it's so profoundly I want to show
you this map this I may hopefully the
the image is all right it's I I know
it's a little blurry this is just one
that I found off my phone that I just
we're putting up um what did you just
tell me there are how many uh Muslim
majority yeah 49 there are 49 Muslim
majority nations in the world how many
Christian majority Nations 15
158 um there's one Jewish one about six
million Jews which is right about the
well I think there's about 9 million now
um but it's look at look at the size of
that country that country is the size of
New Jersey and what you're seeing there
in that odd shape that's cut out that is
the West Bank which is technically part
of Israel and again that's where Jesus
who was a Jew lived that's where the
story of Hanukkah took place anyway you
may not you may not care about any of
this you might be watching this as an
American or or anyone else going well
why why should I give a about any
of this and I suppose that's a perfectly
fine like we can all just bury our heads
in the sand and nobody can care about
anything and there can be no right or
wrong and there can be no morality or
anything else um but but Western Society
the
idea of IND individual rights the idea
of respect for minorities the the basic
ideas that birthed this country were the
basic ideas that birthed Israel that bed
ancient that birthed ancient Greece
right what was Ben Shapiro's book on
this called it's it's a spectacular book
how these what's up the right side of
History how the ideas of Athens and
Jerusalem created the ideas of America
and the West
um put the map up for just a second
again so that so the the point that I'm
showing you this in just a geographic
term is that Sinai so Sinai you see the
long the long arrow on sorry the long
Arrow the the long line on the bottom of
Israel there where it sort of turns into
a long triangle first off the whole
country again it's the size of New
Jersey you can drive north to south in
probably about 5 hours you can drive
east to west it's it's only like eight
miles or something like that it's
unbelievably small um notice the size of
all these other countries there the
Palestinians supposed brother s who care
so much about them nobody will take any
of that actually after I think it was
the 1967 war Israel had all of Sinai
Sinai is that giant pieace that's right
between sort of Israel and Egypt that
giant pieace right there where the Su
the I think that's it's the Suez Canal
sorry I'm a little overloaded at the
moment um Israel had all of that and
they gave it back to Egypt they they
would have had more than their country a
bigger amount of land than their country
was and they gave it back to Egypt for
peace and they basically have had peace
with Egypt but notice that Egypt will
not give that to the Palestinians Saudi
Arabia is not going to invite one
Palestinian in Syria ain't going to
invite anybody turkey Iran it doesn't
matter all these countries that they're
not all Arab but they're they're all
supposedly allies of these people right
but they're not going to bring any of
them in and then the same leftists who
will defend all that will also tell us
that we have to have open borders here
and if you don't think these things are
connected as you see people busting
through borders and murdering innocent
people is it a little bizarre that we've
been watching our own borders be overrun
all right I want to get to Gotti I want
to show you a couple more things uh
Benjamin Netanyahu who by the way was
completely against the withdrawal from
Gaza because he was afraid that this
exact thing would happen 17 years ago at
the time he was not prime minister he
was prime minister before that and
obviously subsequently um he uh here he
is uh declaring war against tamas this
is two days
ago
for
you know I interviewed BB Netanyahu uh
few months ago and it seems to me that
he has lived his whole life for this
moment they'll have to do a postmortem
on what the intelligence failures were
and and they're catastrophic and
extraordinary and where it was this it
almost feels like an inside job at some
level and God only knows what what like
what our Administration was potentially
doing like there's just so much there's
so much disgusting stuff here on how
this could have happened um but I think
that man lived his entire life for this
moment and and I just know that he is
not going to fail his country or his
people and I wish we had more leaders
like that in America um despite all of
this so Israel now is obviously bombing
Gaza despite all of this despite their
wives and children being raped and
murdered and an Untold amount of people
that are just missing 250 kids basically
young people killed at a at a um at a
rave um despite all of that Israel which
is bombing Gaza right now is still as
they always do sending leaflets and
warnings to people in Gaza to leave
meaning leave get out we are going to
bomb you they're raping their children
and Israel is still sending those
warnings and even on the BBC which is
hack leftist trash propaganda that has
helped lead to all of this all of the
confusion that people have around this
issue even in even the BBC is admitting
that that's what Israel is doing right
now last night also the Israeli Army uh
send warning and video messages to
people in Northern Gaza and in South and
in the middle they ask them to leave
some specific areas they draw a map for
the people they show them exactly where
the area which Israel is going to Target
H and they ask them to leave to uh areas
more
secure think about that no other army in
the world including the United States
Army would do that period perod period
we we've done something things like that
in Iraq but in in the midst of this is
this is their 911 per capita it's more
than 911 because they only have about 9
million people so if you know if 1300
people are now dead like you can you can
do the math on that what percentage it
is I think it turns out what would it be
it would be like 200,000 of our people
so it's like unimaginable right and what
are they doing they could bomb the
out of that place and destroy it no look
I think at this point no one to live in
Gaza you have to basically move this my
own personal opinion you guys have
proven what you are you have to move all
of the people to the border with Egypt
and they have to go to Egypt and if
Egypt doesn't want them then let the
rest of the Arab world or something take
them but but you can't have them living
there anymore like you tried you really
tried sorry you you got to go now that's
my own personal opinion on this but even
in the midst of their children missing
and dead and wives raped and all of that
stuff they're sending text messages and
video messages please leave your house
instead of just blowing the out of
everybody if a rocket was shot from
Toronto into Detroit we would bomb
Mexico okay so enough with the moral
equivocation on this thing um here
quickly we'll just show you like 40
seconds of of the IDF starting their
response
[Music]
yeah
note what they have in Gaza they have
buildings they have Apartments they have
hotels they have Seaside Resorts they
have luxury hotels they have restaurants
uh there's a Twitter account that I
shared I can't remember what is off the
top of my head that for years has all
it's been doing basically has been
cataloging all of the luxury items that
are in Gaz tell it's an open air prison
it's aitz like look at a picture of aitz
compared to that all of the people that
you now see raping the Israelis and
murdering them and everything else do
they look starving they're young strong
men who are well fed and and everything
they say it's an open air prison it's
all a extraordinary lie and
until enough of us say we will not play
with these lies anymore whatever the
whatever the horror is that you can
imagine will continue everywhere
basically uh Phoenix has given me the
the per so per capita death toll uh in
Israel is 37 times more than the per
capita death toll on 911 so I I want to
show you two more things and actually
these these are things that I'm uh well
you know I want to do it in the reverse
order actually I want to show you a a
guy by the name of uh Jacob uh phallic
um he's a writer at the daily wire um
and he put up uh this video I think this
morning uh just explaining what what
Israel now has to do and what the
justification for it is and I thought it
was quite good I have a message for
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu the past 48 Hours have not
only been sleepless nights for me but
for millions of Jews around the world on
a weekend we were supposed to be joyous
and intoxicated celebrating the holiday
of
instead we find ourselves sober and
mortified at hundreds of videos of our
people being slaughtered in the streets
children are killed in their homes young
adults and teenagers are killed at
concerts and the elderly are killed at
bus stops no one was spared by The
Animals known as Hamas but BB the lesson
to be learned here is not that Hamas are
animals we've known this for decades
every time they commit a terror act we
are reminded of this lesson time and
time again instead the lesson that needs
to be learned here is that nothing short
of going all the way this time will
bring the Bloodshed of your people to an
end when I say go all the way I don't
mean just bomb the Gaza Strip a little
more than usual when this happens nor do
I mean to increase border security I
mean nothing short of turning the Gaza
Strip into a pile of rubble and
reannexation of a Palestinian State not
only did the Palestinians fail to create
a state the year after they were given
this land the Jews were pulled out of
their homes so that they could have they
elected Hamas an internationally
recognized Terror organization whose
official Covenant said one day Jews were
hide behind rocks and trees and the
rocks and trees will CRA out oh Muslim
oh Muslim there's a Jew hiding behind me
to come and kill him they elected them
as their government that day in 2006 we
should have realized that peace would
have never been a viable option but
instead we find ourselves 17 years and
thousands of deaths later still trying
to understand that reality end the
Bloodshed of your people Benjamin go all
the way this time don't listen to the
activists don't listen to the hypoc
critical International bodies and don't
listen to the leftists in your own
government instead listen to your people
and more importantly listen to your God
numbers
33:55 but if you do not drive out the
inhabitants of the land from before you
then Those whom you leave over will be
as spikes in your eyes and thorns in
your sides and they will harass you in
the land at which you settle pull out
the Thorns BB don't let your words just
be words and people will ask but what
about all of the Palestinians who will
be displaced if they know what's good
for them they will return to the land
which their families came Egypt Syria
Lebanon Jordan make no mistake it is now
an us or them situation and do not think
for a second that any hardship that
falls upon those people are on your
hands it is on the hands of Hamas and on
the hands of their 2006 voting
ballot I mean he's better than anyone
you're going to see on CNN or MSNBC I'll
tell you that I want to show you one
other thing I completely forgot about
this video actually um but Joan Rivers
who has since passed uh in
2014 she was asked about uh what's going
on with with Hamas and Israel as the
last time that not the last time they've
done it many times over the years
including the day after we left Israel
just a few months ago when they were
lobbing Rockets over and you know
building tunnels to to murder people and
everything 2014 she's at an airport and
TMZ asked her what she thought and I
this video I actually was the one I
think that sort of made it go viral I
found it and got it out there uh this is
from years ago but today somehow people
started finding it again and and just
listen to to Joan Rivers I'm trying to
get celebrity reactions to what's going
on with the Palestinians and Israelis
right now let me just tell you if New
Jersey were firing Rockets into New York
we would wipe them out I am so Bor we
heard they were digging tunnels from New
Jersey to New York we would get rid of
Jersey so I don't want to hear anymore
oh we'll do a partial truce the
Palestinians you cannot throw rockets
and expect people not to defend
themselves what about the civilian
casualty rat civilian then don't put
your godamn things in private
homes I'm sorry don't don't you dare put
weapon sashes in in in private homes and
then we say get out of course we're
going to do it the response normally is
where are the where are the civilians
supposed to go I don't care they started
it it is you're all insane they started
it what are you all saying
they started the Israelis did not throw
their for for months this has been going
on how do you what are you supposed to
how do you how I know cuz I have been
over there that's how I know and I wish
the world would know and BBC should be
ashamed for themselves and CNN should be
a sa of themselves and everybody stop it
or you know like Dwight Howard tweeted
free Palestine took it back Selena Gomez
tweeted uh a
praza Gomez oh yeah that college grad
[Laughter]
all right thank you thank you so much
well Selena said
thatana take tell her let's see if she
can spell
Palestinian I'll ask her right now love
you thanks have a great day man only
only Joan Rivers could make you laugh in
the midst of all that um all right
obviously we're gonna have to do more of
this and this is not the way I like to
do a show and I I'm most proud of the
shows that we do when when we're
laughing at the end and I thought man
that was a funny show that that's why
people tune in um but I guess my job now
is a little bit different uh because
clearly this this thing is also going to
just reach into every sort of sector of
society like the world is like we either
stand for truth and and honesty and
reality and Western values or not and
this this just ain't going anywhere for
now um so I want to shift actually for a
second uh my friend Gotti tab is is on
Skype right now he's an Israeli
historian an author he's a screenwriter
he's a political commentator I did a few
events with him when we were in Israel
not too long ago uh he's been battling
uh a lot of the the sort of crazy
leftism that's deeply connected to the
backwards which is why you have Gaye for
Palestine which is very different than
Palestine for Gaye and all of the
confusion around all of this I I don't
even know how to do this properly uh
Gotti Gotti you there yeah yes I am
thank you for your strong words they
they come from the heart and and we can
see them so thanks I hope I did
something that could make a few of you
guys proud um I don't know just tell me
what's going on you're you're in Tel
Aviv at the moment just just take it
away as I was listening to you there
were uh interceptions by Iron doome U
I'm not sure if above my house or
somewhere around the outskirts of Tel
Aviv my cats are sitting here because
they're scared with from these
explosions but what is happening in Tel
Aviv is is nothing what we've seen in in
in the the south of Israel are
atrocities and and images that we
haven't seen since the Holocaust and I'm
glad you mentioned that these barbarians
took a holocaust Survivor an 85y old
Holocaust Survivor as a hostage imagine
this women this woman has been I don't
know how many sleepless nights from
post- trauma in awit and now she's back
in the hands of those
anti-semitic neo-nazis and it's it's
Unthinkable and you see those you see
those images slaughtering children it's
we haven't we came to this country
saying never again never again and I
don't
know what existential apology the
universe can make to this woman who is
now back in the hands of of of those
barbarians so so first of all there's
there's utter shock here and and we're
just beginning to understand what is
going on and everybody was heartwarming
by by by uh President Biden's uh warm
words but we we don't we shouldn't
forget that this has been brewing for a
long time this is an Iranian operation
and the United States has just given
them six billion dollar you've seen
probably the videos of the high-tech
drones that they've used in this
infiltration and so these are the sour
fruits of two terribly misguided
democratic administrations with one
short uh break for Donald Trump and you
need to see the geopolitical uh picture
the what was in the making now is a
peace between Saudi Arabia and Israel
and what we are seeing now is Iran
strategically sacrificing the interests
of the Palestinian people in order to
break this new alignment which is
threatening its strategic interests in
the region because obviously the the the
Palestinian people I don't I have
nothing to say in their favor now they
voted for Hamas H you know if if if you
want to understand the mentality of a
people what who are the heroes on the
names of whom they call schools and
squares and streets you are a hero for
the Palestinian people if you killed
enough Jews that's the one thing that
makes you a hero so we're not on the
road to any peace and and and the
Iranians are trying to turn the
Palestinians into a wedge now between
Israel and Saudi Arabia and and they're
doing it in their in this in this
barbaric way so we have Hamas on the
south and we have Iran's other arm on
the North balah and we have them trying
to Circle us with their prophecies yeah
and and I hope that some of my
explanation again I was doing it all
sort of off the top of my head
and I don't even know what to say
exactly but right right before we
started uh Brock my social media guy
mentioned to me that you know when I saw
you just a few days later back in may we
went up to the north and we looked at
you know one of the Hezbollah Towers
that's literally just like feet away
from the Israeli border and it's like if
the Israelis weren't there they would
gladly jump over the other side but the
Hezbollah doesn't fear that the Israelis
out of nowhere are just going to attack
them like the asymmetry of the thing is
backwards but he showed it to me because
it looks like the tower has now been
destroyed because they're shooting
Rockets over that but I don't even want
to get lost that can you just talk about
the human part of what's going on I mean
I I have no doubt that you know people
that have have probably been killed and
or kidnapped uh just the human part of
and it does it feel like it's at least a
little more controlled within the
borders at the moment or or something a
a little more control they've not they
they've not uh completely taken control
of the situation and what happened I
think is that we were not expecting this
infiltration of Kim of private homes
what they did is they we we don't yet
know how they how they neutralized all
the electronic surveillance apparatuses
but what they did and they plan to do is
to enter civilian settlements like
kibuts overwhelm the guards at the
entrance and then go from house to house
to slaughter people sparing no one and
the videos are so atrocious you you
can't you can't show them on your show
Dave you can't you can't even put them
on social media some of them are this is
this is a a snuff for ography of of of
evil and and you I I don't want to start
describing them but but people in Israel
have lost their sense of security and so
now we're talking about uh giving arms
to civilians and the minister of
national security has now loosened our
gun laws usually we have a lot of guns
you know a lot of people are in reserve
service and we have a lot of guns but
they are not enough and if we are going
if if indeed we are going to a two-front
war withal to we have a only a limited
uh size for an army and we are going to
have to massively arm ourselves because
the the the scary thing with this is you
don't know where it will come from what
do you make of sort of the existential
misunderstanding of Israel and the
history of the Jews and again I tried to
do some basic simple history there but
like the amount of stupidity and
ignorance that is flaunted everywhere
and that NBC constantly shows this map
of how Palestine has disappeared over
the years even though there was never a
country called Palestine or a people
known as Palestinians etc etc um the the
average Israeli must walk around with
that knowing that in some ways it does
not matter we just have to survive and
they will lie about us and it just is
what it
is first of all the we have a woke
contingent in our Elites too and you and
I have been fighting basically the same
War in our separate countries but note
that what they've managed to do over the
years is turn the language of Human
Rights into the new vehicle of
anti-Semitism now human rights
organizations are demonizing Israel in
the language of Human Rights so if you
if you're an historian you look back at
history then they've been saying for
decades that Jews have Slaughter been
slaughtering Christian kids for our mats
in Passover and now they use human
rights organizations in order to Port
betay the Jewish State as a murderer of
children while we have murderers of
children on the other side look as
benjam nanyu said so clearly we protect
our women and children with rockets they
protect their Rockets with women and
children and it's time we stopped
flinching that this blood is on their
hands and we are trying to play a in in
an ultr moral um uh way of behavior in a
conflict where we are facing barbarians
with no moral Scruples at all and we
should in in the very least H give the
right impression that we this time
around we are not going to stop because
of some Goldstone report that turns out
to be fake and full of full of blood
liels in the language of Human
Rights I don't even know what what else
to ask you is there is there anything
else you want to say for now I mean
obviously I'll have you on whenever you
want to come back on and I'll I'll
gladly have anyone that you think I
should have on and all of that but I'll
be glad to be to be back and you're
doing uh great work I think the work
that that that people should do on on on
on your side in United States is don't
let the Biden Administration cheat you
about Iran they're strengthening Iran
they're stepping over Israel's Head
they're doing it in a Sly way they've
loosened all the sanctions on this state
that's that has a religious goal of
erasing the Jewish people from the face
of the Earth and they're playing this
game it started with the Obama
Administration it goes on with the Biden
Administration we still know there are
Iranian spies inside this Administration
and it's it's appeasing the worst Force
ever so this is a chamberlan mistake and
Americans should point it out got I
thank you for your time I will say a
prayer for you I know that that
literally millions of Americans and and
more than that all over the world are
doing just that and uh I mean it anytime
I'm deeply touched Dave thank you for
all the good work that you're doing all
right um okay this was a bit of a
different show I suppose than we
normally do around here uh we are going
to do a postgame show for for locals we
can just talk it out I suppose I know we
have some members of the locals
community that are in Israel right now
actually so if you want to join us it's
Ruben report. locals.com and uh we we'll
do it again
[Music]
tomorrow